[Music]
[Applause]
oh hello and welcome back to the break
room this is our daily show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know I hate some of those words
what are the words what are the words
you don't like uh
coming up on the show today we have some
interest interesting new quantumania
dialogue yeah we got Agatha and a top
hat uh and break room's first ever Movie
Club it's gonna be great uh if you don't
know about that watch Knives Out on uh
eight times speed before we get to the
movie club
headphones uh I'm Brandon Barrick who
cares at the end of the table today we
got John Costa who cares no that's mine
oh [__] that's my line next to me we got
Tommy bechtold great to be here with you
oh starting eyes closed eyes closed
it's going to be a really good clean
episode oh good clean episode yeah you
told me before we started if we raise
100 and Super Chat you kiss me like that
that thing in The Last of Us I haven't
seen that show I don't know what that
means you don't know what that means uh
it's just neck kisses uh we raise five
thousand dollars
I'll put something in this set inside me
nothing inside of you stop something of
the chat's choice this show is already I
just heard it what from HR we're getting
gasps around the uh the crowd it's at 5
000 guys We're not gonna get there we
are live sending those super chats if
you feel like it today we're having a
great Friday we hope you are too uh
we're live right here from our break
room at new Rockstar's headquarters and
it's time to get into the headlines
it's always weird um when there's
Silence of that graphic I should shorten
it they they don't hear silence
our first headline today Captain America
New World Order adds Joshua rockmore to
its cast Joshua was recently in Space
Jam 2 and the season three finale of
Atlanta uh her role is being kept Under
Wraps even though the headline for this
was like major players
and I was like okay unwrap those rolls
is anyone else struggling to see that
title without thinking you have WCW at
19. oh I mean anytime I see new world
order at all I think is like new new
world order I I'm sure there's this a
sliver of fans out there that feel the
same way yeah I'm just waiting for this
like this is an old person reference the
companion movie will be buggy Barnes in
the wolf pack that's right and don't
turn your pack on the wolf pack that's
true it's true too sweet too sweet uh
next headline we got a new TV spot for
Ant-Man the WASP quantumania we're gonna
be seeing lots of these little spots
coming out both in here in the U.S and
internationally they all have little
different things in them in this new TV
spot we saw Cassie refers to the quantum
device as a two-way radio this little
the thing with the blue light that sucks
them all in the initial second if you
will uh but who do we think she was
talking to on the other side of this
two-way radio was a good old Uncle
krylar we're assuming that's her uncle
would it be her uncle uh no technically
not it would be well then she's not
related yeah
if she considers them grandparents I
guess this would be like when your
grandmother went on a weird vacation and
came back with yeah what do you call it
a tan and three other kids
what do you call like your grandparents
cousin what is that to you is that also
your cousin I think that you call them a
ghost ghost
uh we were talking about this earlier
because this whole idea of this device
being a two-way radio
that was something we had talked about
very yeah because in the Comic-Con
footage that had come out that was not
ever widely released was put into
subsequent uh trailers though that was a
line of dialogue that was there and then
was never a really widespread released
until now you know what if it was like a
distressed call from that sort of like
resistance group you know that we've
seen those new photos
that could be interesting because I
don't think she would just has a line of
communication with Kang because you know
I mean she is keeping this device from
her grandparents you'd think that Janet
would sort of say like I know that voice
who are you talking to in the other room
nobody stop it oh sorry I think it's
probably I mean Cassie is uh uh uh over
the age of 18 at this point in in the
MCU if it's inappropriate for Kang to be
messaging such a young true true true I
should shouldn't be doing that I bet you
maybe he's in maybe he's pulling like a
um a Hans Gruber and diode where he's
pretending to be like a like a oh I'm
stuck down here oh no I'm dropped down
oh please don't shoot
that's a great his American accent that
uh segment of Die Hard is great uh I've
never seen die hard though because I was
born in 2002. oh next movie Club movie
The Next Movie Club movie
yeah uh I think both if it's not
available for streaming I think both Mt
and Eric have pointed out that that the
quantity device it has like a little
keyboard attached to it yeah and that
could be for just activating but the the
radio part might be like it's more like
talking yeah like it's like uh we've
ever lost we're the Lost computer you're
too young you're too young what's lost
uh it's a show uh that I love because
that early Comic-Con footage too I think
it also implied that like she was
building this because of a way like Hey
Dad when you were gone and I had no way
I was trying to talk to you if I had had
this device I could have talked to you I
want to make sure this never never
happens again never happens again uh so
we'll have to wait and see I mean I I
agree that I don't think she's talking
to King I I like the idea that she's
talking it's just someone that Scott
owes money to or get those money too hey
this is Maury can you tell your dad that
the quantum Jets lost to the quantum
49ers and uh unfortunately under also
hit so I'm gonna need 500 Quantum bucks
from them by Monday before I break his
Quantum fingers I got to suck you in and
shrink your legs okay so uh Tommy's got
to go to Quantum Jersey or as we call it
the toilet oh boy here we go again uh uh
and next up my new set photos from
Agatha coven of chaos uh show Catherine
Han and Joe Locke probably just doing
something innocent at an Orange Julius
or something in a mall uh there are
these set photos uh uh what an odd
costume Zach called her the Madewell
witch ah yes I love this yeah she's
she's wearing a top hat and like some
kind of flowy blouse I think I think
they were filming the show somewhere
else and she just tried to go to lunch
well some people were saying does this
take place before she snaps out of the
sort of wine put her in she's wearing
black and white which is like how Wanda
left her in that but like Smith Wickham
who this is all following me
my theories my predictions was there
another photo we had from this we have
one more it was just it's they rebranded
them all they call it the one not the
Westfield Mall uh we didn't we never
obviously saw a mall in the show uh we
kind of I we got to you know one of the
one when it was when they were changing
from the town from the hex version to
the real version it looked like they
kind of passed over a Sears or something
like that something like that yeah we
saw like the downtown area a bustling
downtown that was when the hex went away
we saw how it was in disrepair yeah uh
so sometimes gentrification via hex is a
good thing oh yeah yeah Revitalize the
area yeah I might wouldn't it be nice to
just have someone take over your brain
and you can just relax
sell my house for a nice markup yeah
absolutely it'd be lovely uh but yeah
we're of course looking forward to the
show those hotels obviously but it's
good to see they're in production it's
moving forward all that good stuff I
don't want to be spoiled on it so if we
get any other more provocative set
photos please don't show them yeah we
were getting some of the uh we're
getting some of the little clips and
glimpses of Loki season two in that like
Sizzle reel that they put out and I'm
not even seeing that I was like oh this
might be too much fun I know it might be
too much for me it's fun having a sequel
to a Disney plus Marvel series we
haven't gotten one of those yeah
um speaking of which that's the lead
topic of today's discussion yes we just
want to give everyone an update uh about
where the hell is
oh God I'll fix it I thought I put it in
yeah I've got it in front of me okay uh
we want to give everyone an update on
like what what's happening with these
Disney plus Series right like we thought
we would kind of have a second secret
invasion trailer here by now but we we
don't
um so I'm going to just run through all
the 2023 releases not necessarily on the
phase five ones but everything's
supposed to come out this year so you
can all kind of go home with a better
understanding of yeah what the heck's
happening these are just the Disney plus
Marvel series yes we've heard so much
about them we're getting along these
things but what's what now right right
so
uh I'm gonna start with animation let's
just start with the animated ones uh
back in July we got some updates about
some of these shows release dates what
if season two they said early 2023 right
around right here right around now it's
early 2023. they showed a full episode
at Comic-Con uh so so there's one in the
can sitting around so we also knew there
was one episode that they moved from
season one to season two yeah it didn't
seem like that was the episode that they
showed for people though uh that episode
we think was like uh Tony Stark and what
kind of thing because there was like an
Iron Man suit and there was something
Gamora was cut out of yeah was in the
Thanos armor yeah stuff yeah yeah but
the episode that they showed it at
Comic-Con if memory serves was uh a
continuation of the uh
you know the last the the post-credits
scene basically from what if where
um
thank you thank you and what we know of
the events of the first Avengers
Avengers Assemble for you you folks in
the UK uh the moment of the Tesseract
opening and Loki coming out and said and
what if it was Captain Carter coming out
with like uh tentacles yeah
but also I'm talking about as well the
Steve Rogers in the in the mark one Iron
Man suit yeah that weird iron mongerisk
yeah so uh some some kind of frustrating
news with that show right the trailer
for this first season of what if came
out in December 2020. that show
premiered in August
2021. so they did about you know eight
months of nine months nine months from
from Trailer release to Episode One
release so you know I don't know if
we're gonna exactly follow that model
but nine months from now certainly is
not early 2021 2023.
um we have her looks like some some kind
of like grumbling underground
unconfirmed rumors that that show is
getting moved to the end of the year uh
to accommodate for what I don't know
because it kind of takes place outside
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
hopefully it just means that they're
spending the time to make these episodes
better or these are just rumors we don't
know we don't know we haven't said
anything unfortunately but you know
um yeah I don't know it's it doves Tails
into the the other animation topics
which is we're also supposed to get
X-Men 97 this year uh that was going to
be a fall release or it's still kind of
technically legislated to be a fall
release we've also heard sort of similar
Rumblings both Rumor Mill online and
some of the things that you know we hear
at new rockstars we have you know our
kind of fingers and a lot of pies that
that uh that may be getting blinked in
2024 so I wouldn't be surprised with
that what if uh show kind of sits in
that fall slot okay and then at
Comic-Con they didn't show any clips
from
and some images but we've not seen like
any Clips or anything like that yeah you
know I think they showed like an
animatic maybe or something like that
but not not an episode and for for some
people you might be thinking like anime
show like this should come out they
could do this overnight or whatever but
it's like sometimes animation takes
longer than a standard production
because they have to like we saw we
forgot to put this in the headlines
today with the Invincible trailer that
we came out today they were kind of
making fun of the fact that like this
[__] takes a long time to make you know
like maybe the end yeah and it's like
they don't know still right it takes
time to do the voice acting and you know
the drawing and like sending off to fix
it and then making changes all that good
stuff yeah so so that's sort of what
Marvel's animation slate was gonna look
like this year uh you still have Marvel
zombies and Spider-Man freshman year
those were already slated for 2024 uh so
not gonna be this year anyway so we
might just get one if this year that
might be okay
um moving on to live action though
um like it's not great news across the
board I don't want to preface that right
um we we got that first trailer for
secret invasion of d23 back in August
September somewhere somewhere in there
yeah yeah
um
now they were teasing in early 2023
release for that too uh they said spring
on their phase five graphic if we could
pull that up
yep there it is spring uh 2023 and they
sort of the way that they do this is
they kind of like nudged it barely very
close barely to the right Mania so that
made us think like oh probably it'll
come out after quantumania that's how
they normally kind of do these things
um
the thing with that right is that like
if you again we try to be sluice here at
interactions if you follow the kind of
trailer release pattern Mandalorian
season three just got its second trailer
right right last week that's scheduled
to come out March 1st right so if you
kind of follow Disney's marketing
department a little bit
um if we got a new trailer next week
we'd be like oh yeah like middle
something like that they've overlapped
Marvel and Star Wars shows in the past
maybe not super successfully for them
right like I think they found that when
they put Kenobi out with Miss Marvel
Miss Marvel kind of suffered and when
they put out She-Hulk and Andor at the
same time Andor kind of suffered it's
weird that there's been nothing for a
while now it is weird it is weird last
year we had Hawkeye around the holidays
and book a Boba Fett started yeah in
between uh uh I think the next week or
something yeah yeah like the week after
it ended so yeah I see your point John
because maybe they don't want to double
stack a week with two of big shows but
also so like we know someone there must
have a chart of like yeah right yeah
right extensively the people who worked
on the show fire up are like the show's
coming out this day well that's the
other pieces I haven't pulled the
trigger on saying that that's another
piece of pipe Marvel Disney Plus shows
have been notoriously kind of slow at
announcing their release dates right uh
I I think uh we only just learned the
March 1st release date for
um
a few weeks ago right no I think we
learned what was it just on Monday they
announced it in the trailer right so you
know who knows they could just kind of
be like it's coming next month and let
me get a new trailer and all that kind
of stuff uh if we're going back to that
same kind of source that we have for
these rumors again unsubstantiated
they're just rumors uh people say not
until May which would be a total bummer
I guess technically Still Still spring
still spring if you pull that phase five
graphic up again uh we'll see you know
May 5th is Guardians of the Galaxy
volume three does it come out that first
week of May and and be Guardians of the
Galaxy a little bit I think that they'd
you know not want to overlap those two
programs as well it would be close they
don't want to run into Loki yeah
um who would want to run into local that
guy's mischievous hat yeah well and
speaking of which you know we saw echo
on that graph uh was sort of for this
right around the dog's coughing is not
perform in the corner uh right around
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. 10 grand
I eat the dog
um save your money folks we have heard
Jesus Christ uh
we've heard from the head writer of that
show uh late last year she was sort of
like yeah it's probably going to come
around come out around this time next
year so so she kind of hinted that it's
probably not going to come out until
December 2023 at the earliest right that
one is sort of our most guaranteed to
get pushed which one is that again
uh this this rumors thing is saying it
might be 2024. who knows yeah who knows
again who knows so I know it's like it's
like the worst news possible I don't
think that long
for the benefit of these shows that's
right yeah it's a little better I think
a lot of people were sitting there
saying like ooh phase four it felt
rushed it didn't feel completed you look
at at Thor love and thunder and I think
like one of the things that I felt
coming out of that movie was you know
they shot a lot of the stuff on the
volume and that felt practical for covid
reasons and and all that kind of stuff
so I'm totally fine with them kind of
looking at their slate and saying you
know hey let's just slow this down a
little bit we don't need to put out 55
000 things a year I think Kevin feige
when Multiverse of Madness was coming
out there was a quote going around that
was like you know oh he picked
um
he picked Sam Raimi the director for
that movie because Sam raimey was like
so established and so like he could be
so hands off I think Kevin feige has a
million meetings a day I'm sure so you
know slowing this down a little bit
maybe means he can be a little bit more
Hands-On okay
um so that's Echo that's getting that's
probably pushed now the good news right
is that like we've heard no kind of push
news about both Loki season 2 and Iron
Heart you know Loki season two uh is one
of the only things we've seen footage
from apart from the trailer we got for
secret Invasion
um we've seen you know four or five
shots Eric put out a breakdown of those
shots in the channel a couple of weeks
ago some really cool exciting stuff that
started that shot uh summer of last year
so they should be finishing this they
had a Sizzle reel at d23 yeah oh yeah it
sounded really cool from the
descriptions you guys said yeah um so so
that looks like it's ready to go and
that you know for us here that's like my
most anticipated show of this year
definitely um we're in Last of Us season
right now which I'm really enjoying but
after that show I think Loki is sort of
the first sequel show for a Disney plus
to come out like quickly announced to be
a sequel as the show ended that's right
yeah they loved it so much they were
like we got to make a second season
we're gonna change the ending Heron who
made the first season was like I don't
want to do a second she was like I had
this story to tell and if you guys want
to keep running with it fine but like
and uh and Michael Waldron uh has sort
of patched the torch for that show as
well he's you know obviously wrote
Multiverse of Madness in this off
reading Fantastic Four
he's writing a future Marvel project and
a future Star Wars project that Kevin
feige is also producing if you're
watching please call him
and then as we all know with ironheart
if I can give a quick update please
shit's lit shit's lit that's right thank
you Anthony Ramos if you're listening
you can't be clean he's gonna shove a
dog carcass up his ass if we get ten
thousand dollars no I'm gonna eat the
well you know what either way in or out
the dog's going in me today oh my god oh
god
um okay so you guys ready for some more
bad news you ready for support hit me
with the bad news we just saw our first
episode of Agatha chaos you're shooting
right now yes sounds like it shot sounds
like a shot some stuff uh before the
break in December but they're fully in
production right now yeah here's this
weird rumor that kind of puts everything
into context for me in in a maybe all
these rumors are [__] kind of a way
now that it was slated to release sort
of late 2023 into 24 similar to The Book
of Boba Fett stuff that they did last
year
um there's this rumor
that they're gonna save it for 2025.
after after Daredevil born again I don't
see how those two shows are connected
right I don't see why you would say like
we wanted to slightly change the story
of Kevin of chaos yeah it's got to take
place after Daredevil born again and
that shows a little further away from
production it's 18 episodes it's going
to take them a long time to get rolling
on that one I don't see why they would
do that and continue production now why
shoot it now right yeah so that kind of
tells me like okay these rumors that
we're hearing maybe some of them have a
little bit of Truth to them maybe some
of them don't uh but I mean the great
news is that shooting right now and I
think like we are all pretty familiar
with
um
you know Film Production and development
and it seems like that show probably the
six episodes of that show or I think
it's nine episodes because it's their
shorter episodes could probably be
turned around by the end of the year
yeah right okay maybe yeah maybe so yeah
and to your point if anything it seems
like iron heart and Covenant of chaos
we're going to be more closely related
it was being put in Iron Heart right uh
so I don't know and they also had Iron
Heart footage at d23 yeah so they did
preface it that it was very early
footage it was all practical stuff I
don't think there was any effects
yeah I was shooting around then in
August that one is obviously has way
more visual effects to take care of than
something like Covenant of chaos does
but still uh if you pull up the phase
five graphic one last time you can see
uh oh we changed it never mind
Iron Heart used to be slated to come out
right after blade and the blades date
was November 7th 2023 so that'll
probably come out in that November uh
window yeah we haven't really heard much
about ironheart moving it seems like
they're still aiming for that fall
window so yeah Loki and iron heart are
the two that were sort of like oh yeah
these seem like they're gonna come out
come on out guys
um
so that's kind of where we're at okay
with with the Disney plus series for
this year I'm expecting Kevin feige to
rock up on stage and like some kind of
Agatha all along was the person creating
these rumors that all these shows are
getting delayed and maybe they're
totally fine
um I mean I'm a full-time procrastinator
so if I was like a head writer on this
show I'd be seating those rumors of like
sure yeah it looks like well
interestingly enough again we we know
some folks that work at Marvel and
apparently according to them they just
don't know when their shows are coming
out they don't know they they're in the
same boat as us I mean I'm sure they're
aware like where I'm sure they're aware
about like production timelines and
finishing and they kind of know like
roughly how far along the show is in its
creation and it's finishing but uh
they're not like hey your show's got to
come out on this day so we gotta get
everything done by then or I'm told some
of the animators on what if thought they
were just doing paintings maybe for for
a gallery beautiful yeah it's
rockwell-esque
paintings uh well thank thank you for
all that information yeah I'm sorry it
couldn't have all been great I know you
know it is you know what you know some
days you get chicken salad some days you
get chicken [__] that's right that's
right uh you know it's very few I I
would almost say only Marvel's in this
kind of weird position hopefully DC will
be there very shortly month is almost
over uh of of kind of having to Babe
Ruth their slate for the next couple of
years it'd be like right here's where
everything's gonna come out well I guess
obviously things are going to change I
guess that's some of the good news which
is Marvel or I'm sorry Disney put out
they sort of like quarterly will put out
a press release to uh press and theaters
that is like here's our upcoming movie
slave for the next four years or
whatever it is uh they put another one
of those out today no changes to the
Marvel slate right right so every movie
that they've already kind of announced
is is at least as of now holding its
release date so this is just the shows
they're kind of moving around but it
seems like the movies at least for the
next couple years are pretty set and the
show's moving is also wasn't like oh you
know Agatha starting uh September 3rd
2023 they were like right it's gonna be
late yeah wait I don't know I like late
replacing maybe Disney doesn't follow
the normal you know uh uh Sun calendar
yeah follow the Equinox Caesar yeah it
doesn't apply to our Seasons maybe
they're on the Australia I think they
have seven months one for each beautiful
duel
uh hey let's be coming out in late
snoozy uh some of our great super
Chatters Christian unpronounceable said
I just love you guys and everyone in the
chat I I love everyone here sometimes
kind of [__] uh but in a way that I
love everyone in the chat knows how I
feel about them I think they're absolute
trash in guavois also sending a Super
Chat saying always watch out for Kanger
danger that's right we're communicating
with strangers online don't talk to us
I don't know if Chris Hansen would want
to show up at King conquers house on
Dateline okay can you have a seat
probably not end well we had you talking
with Cassie Cassie Lang when she was
only 16 years old I yeah I was just
chatting with him
you asked her to buy a bottle of bottles
of James wine cooler King
what do you think he asked the kid to
buy bottles again
well he's in the corner
with a bunch of Bartles and James and
put it next to them hey that's do me a
favor get 40 McNuggets also I don't know
what Bartles and James is because I
actually don't know actually if you're
20 you probably do know what part of
they still make bottles and James oh
yeah yeah do you think you know that's
the real secret to pimtech is just uh
make your piles booze a little bit
bigger than last you longer wine coolers
they don't have the punch wine coolers
turned into seltzers those are yeah
those are the new wine cores what a
Gambit
go back to the wine coolers I miss them
I miss sitting out by a by a by a body
of water and feeling like absolute trash
after two of them your stomach just like
basically drinking alcoholic Kool-Aid a
horrible time for all you can still get
some Mad Dog 20 20. that's a malt
product though hey it's Friday here at
the breakup we're having a great time we
have not been drinking no we have not
obviously judge we hope you are too but
this is a big day okay it's almost time
for a break room Movie Club this is the
first one ever
before we get to that we want to thank
nordvpn for sponsoring our show today
and all week uh and they're the ones
that made our break room Movie Club
possible as a reminder with just one
click just one easy click and here's a
here's a pro tip you can even automate
this so you don't even have to click the
nordvpn turns on automatically but you
know what I wanted to tell you to throw
out the copy today because I've been
using your VPN and I wanted to say a
couple okay throw it out you're right
just one click and the cool thing too
I'm going to give you a testimonial
they've got all these well so I I have
to use vpns a lot for work I won't get
into why
um and one of the things I really like
about Nord is they have like a bunch of
recommended servers to connect to which
I imagine they do based on proximity and
speed of the servers and all that kind
of stuff but there's also a really handy
search function because we knew that
Knives Out was on uh Japanese Netflix we
were going to watch that for a movie
club you can just search for the country
that you want and like I mean they're in
I think 60 different countries 60
countries over 5400 servers so many so
like and they have the way that they do
their countries are they're like in
they're in major countries so they're
countries with big Netflix libraries
essentially right I don't know if they
did that on purpose but like you know
it's not like they're they're putting
their servers in like uh Lithuania or
whatever yeah tiny little uh
um so that being said it's it was super
easy and then the other great feature
that I didn't know about and people who
have vpns maybe will be excited about
this too
um I sometimes will turn off my VPN
because there's some stuff I want to do
without using a VPN
um I always forget to turn it back on
Nord has this really Nifty like handy
little pause feature and you can choose
like 30 minutes up to five hours or
something like that so you don't have to
remember to turn it back on and they
have all these other privacy features
you can you can have a you can store
your passwords with Nord like you know
ultimately at the end of the day a VPN
is really useful for protecting your
privacy online it's becoming more and
more important than ever Nord sort of
has this like really great top to bottom
privacy program uh that includes
password protection and password
management and vpns and all that kind of
stuff
and you can use it on like up to six
devices so it's not just your computer
like on your phone on like smart TVs
things like that one and speaking of Geo
blocking it's you know it's football
season right now I would set my location
I'm a Jets fan
I would set my location to New York and
I would get to watch this
I would get to watch the Jets and then
uh I can set I can turn the VPN off and
it would continue to work and I could go
do all my others it was great like
setting my location to Toronto to watch
the Bills I mean I'm I'm pretty I'm
pretty much a tech novice and like
nordvpn sent us like everything it does
and they have a section of like here's
what we do if you actually understand
this and I didn't understand any of it
off so if you if you barely knew how to
use your computer nordvpn is helpful if
you're really smart and you're like I
don't need it check it out they have a
lot of cool things yeah and it's a very
useful service and they're the best out
there they got the best speed baby uh
they'll always keep you streaming and
that Chris speaking of it speaking of
privacy did you notice that
um uh what's his name uh the Chris Evans
character in knives out he uses uh
proton male which is like an encrypted
mail service that's right he would be
using I'm not saying I'm not saying that
murderer
so if you're thinking of using a VPN or
committing a murderer
check out our exclusive nordvpn offer at
nordvpn.com break room you'll get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift and if you're worried like I
don't want to do this as risky it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee again an exclusive
gift just for our break room fans out
there go to nordvpn that's
nordvpn.com
and grab it now while we still have this
deal going because we're going to be
doing Nord VPN Movie Club next month
yeah so you got the 30 day money back
guarantee use it for the 30 days we'll
be back we'll do another yeah we'll give
you we'll deal within 30 days you can
join us on the movie club uh and if you
don't love it then that's totally fine
and don't forget it's like I always say
if you're worried about the price even
Tommy can afford to go with North
it's time for our break room Movie Club
it's our first one ever we watched
Knives Out in Japan or on Japanese I
flew to Japan you didn't get North I got
confused I didn't get ignored in time so
I charted a a jet to Japan set settled
into my hotel got an Amazon fire stick
and then I uh downloaded Netflix and
watched it it's not it's not currently
streaming in the US right now uh you
have to purchase it which is so which is
so weird because I pitched this movie
for Movie Club and everyone's like it's
on Netflix and we're like well no Glass
Onion is why wouldn't Netflix
you know it's probably this movie was
probably people were dying to buy this
indication right to this movie if you
don't remember it basically blew up at
the box office it was like it was still
pretty fresh into covet and it was like
oh there's something to go see we can go
see this movie yeah uh surprise hit so
we watched it again we helped some of
you at home watched it uh too uh and
here's my first question for you guys
yes
um and if you out there in the chat if
you have any lingering questions your
thoughts send them in John's gonna be
watching the chat say hi to John hello
uh we'll get to some of your questions
some of your thoughts I accidentally
sent someone as a moderator uh-oh sorry
Ernie H-Town you're no longer a
moderator
Ernie you flew too close my first
question for both of you guys you know
we've seen Glass Onion now right yeah
going back to Knives Out well that
really stood out for you because you
both had seen it before I'd seen it
before but I had not seen it again since
watching Glass Onion I mean first of all
right like these I've seen I had seen
knives out twice before this re-watch
and I had seen Glass Onion twice and
it's just like it still continues to be
so rewarding on a re-watch the
screenplay is written so smartly where
like you see the dogs at the beginning
and it always comes it's just like
there's so many great breadcrumbs so
many you know those are like classic
Agatha Christy moments yes that they do
in this movie that you just kind of get
reminded of so smart I for me there's
two uh two things that when I rewatched
it that I remember feeling kind of like
very moved by Christopher Plummer's
performance with you know not a ton of
screen time but like just his
relationship with Marta uh was I think
just so was was such a such a beautiful
uh like cinematic relationship between
that was not made like dirty old man
resting after and she did not have
malicious intent right well and you know
what it's like a really smart
juxtaposition for that is like I didn't
realize first time watching it was like
he was probably really desperate yeah
for family yes right his family is such
a piece of [__] they all failed him and
this is like the only and of course like
it's it's so obvious on the surface he
puts her in the will and all that kind
of stuff
um and so like literally like makes her
you know not literally makes her part of
his family but you know typically your
will is mostly for family
um and so like having his family be so
shitty and that being like really the
only relationship that he has and
cherishes yeah he's so smart the second
yes I completely agree and the second
thing was how intimidating that house
was how just like please
the different levels and like the like
the weird exposed like Stone balconies
that you could go out I was like man
this is a house that if I rented as an
Airbnb and had a couple Bartles and
games
every corner multiple places I mean [__]
who has that crazy art piece with the
circular knives in the house
you know where do you think that thing
is oh like it's not in Ryan Johnson's
basement oh he has it's not in his
basement it's in his living room
probably I've never seen my Mike
Flanagan's office where it's like a ton
of movie memorabilia Ryan Johnson seems
to cut from that same car to me like
that that knife sculpture is there it's
it's got to live somewhere yeah oh sorry
go ahead I was just gonna say one thing
that really stood out to me watch this
movie again was just how different it
was from glass totally that was a big
reminder and I was like ah this is great
and like the movie starts with the dead
body yeah it gets right into it where
it's like Glass Onion takes some time to
get to the murder and like I was just
like so much fun going back to this
movie and it was a it was so good Jimmy
Lee Curtis killing it like Don
he had like such a good year I think it
was like Watchmen and knives out all
kind of came out around the same time
yeah a couple questions from the chat
Mary Smith is wondering is it
appropriate for 13 year olds is it rated
R oh
I think so I mean I don't know your kid
but there's no I would say there's no
like graphic section yeah there's not
even my graphic violence right and I
think if anything I think this is a I
saw Terminator 2 way too young yeah so I
think you're fine
in the movie would be Christopher
Plummer on the living yeah so yes uh and
that is fairly car it's fairly
theatrical blood and violence you know a
movie like this I remember being uh
young which was only like eight years
ago from right right but like a movie
like this these are the types of movies
that if this is like this could be a 13
year old's first movie to be like yeah
well I I love movies yeah yeah and like
a movie as a kid too you you may watch
movies so much more I feel like yeah
like this it is so rewarding I Remember
Loving clue as a kid yeah uh which is a
movie
the origin of the term Easter yeah yeah
yeah yes yeah uh um and like that's a
movie that was way too adult for me yeah
me too but like well and you know what
there's some jokes in this original
knives out that flew over my head the
first time I watched it and it's not
like I've grown up so much since the
first year now yeah but you know it is
one of those movies that there will
probably be things that like Miss a 13
year old and then they can re-watch it
in a couple years and pick up on a
couple more things and I'll say just
personal experience I watch Glass Onion
with my 13 year old nephew oh great and
you know I don't think I mean he
certainly is he's crying because he
should might have seen you watch Child's
Play and that was not good it's got a
dog every Halloween I saw Child's Play
way too young as well yeah but I but I
but like yeah I don't like afterwards I
did some basic neurological tests on him
and he seemed intact so so yeah Lily and
gal uh who is our biggest uh military
fund stand since they saw seven when she
was uh seven when she was seven oh which
you know hey
another question for the chat uh Freight
girls wondering did anyone did anyone of
us know what the game go was before
watching the movie no the game that they
play and they spill so I I took a class
in college one of my least favorite
classes ironically enough that was like
all about games and go was like one of
the most like first strategy games and
it inspired a bunch of the other stuff
so I did know what go was but I still
don't want to play it ah yeah no it's
like Othello I'm very aware of the game
you have no idea how to play it yeah
great play foreign
who won the movie for you on this
additional viewing and I will take out
Daniel Craig Benoit Blanc I think yeah
obviously won the movie the first time
around for everyone simply for the
pronunciation of murder I'm just he has
a simple obvious
for me after watching everything
everywhere all at once and that kind of
being my favorite movie of last year
um
uh I Gotta Give it to uh Jamie Lee Curt
I was thinking Jamie listed Spears in my
head Jamie Lee Curtis
ing the end of that movie that also kind
of gets what she wanted which is like
she finds out that her husband is
cheating on her you know and so she has
a really satisfying sort of ending she's
great she's so fun
I mean Michael Shannon has that bottled
rage but that's just like constant for
Michael Shannon right like when he's at
the grocery store and ask the produce
guy something I'm sure the produce guy
is like is he gonna kill me I don't
understand where the cantaloupes uh but
like yeah she's great I mean for me it
was Don Johnson like yeah I mean just
making a meal out of everything just
like having the best time and like I the
reveal when they're getting interviewed
at the beginning and like everyone kind
of like looks to camera at some point
and it's like who is that sure they're
looking at them look at you yeah that's
so good what about you Tommy I you know
I gotta be basic on this America's ass
Chris yeah uh I mean I would even go
further just his sweaters playing
against type chunky sweaters chunky
sweaters all right I think I honestly
think Android phones
I think Knives Out might have been the
movie to convince him to leave the MCU
yeah you know I think he sat there and
was like this was so fun it's so not me
I got to play characters
it was Ransom well he was insane too
right because in uh Avengers end game
when Loki when we see when they go in
the Time Heist and they go back to the
Battle of New York and Loki's getting a
rest or whatever and Loki turns into
Chris Evans and does like
just Chris Evans getting to do that yeah
I want to not be like the straight man
anymore
evil guy and he is great in it and again
like when you re-watch the movie it's
like from the jump they're like yeah he
left the party early he was angry and
he's like obviously like him but like
that's my favorite part about these
movies is that they kind of tell you who
the bad guy is before they ask you
before the murder happens right you know
yeah yeah like you knew you knew he was
the [__] murderer right you knew that
Edward Norton spoilers for Glass Onion
it was the murderer
um but then the movie is sort of like no
he's not for a long time right right you
know which is really fun yeah uh yeah
and especially comparing this to like uh
Glass Onion you know I think Ryan
Johnson did such a good job with glass
on you're making it so different and
also playing on the audience being like
okay I'm gonna Knives Out Collection
movie they should be called the Benoit
Blanc Saga which I think Ryan Johnson
wanted he didn't want him I think he
just wanted to call it Glass Onion well
and the story uh but like in that movie
you're you're constantly being like okay
I'm gonna figure this one out baby and
like you're every and there's so many
red herrings in that one uh and like
from the jump and was like here's how
the middle of that and then you're like
what the movies were not even starting
uh but this one is like going back and
you're like okay I want to figure it out
and see if all the clues are there and
they are there but like you didn't know
when you watched it the first time you
weren't ready to be like well and it's
like it does This brilliant thing where
it's like you don't know what's a clue
and what's just kind of out of place you
know there's a bunch of stuff where
you're like because like he picks up the
the broken piece of the Terrace or
whatever right and you're like oh like
who is this leading to and it's leading
the honor to armis and so you like
there's Clues everywhere and they're
leading to different killers they just
don't exactly know yeah like the weird
little uh right teenage that was someone
said in the chat uh gosh where is it and
not super important but the Nazi
masturbating line was their favorite
thing yeah I mean so much good dialogue
in the movie yeah which is like out of
this world uh where would you guys like
to see this franchise go next I mean
they're gonna make more what are we
talking about they've got two more I
think that he signed on I think Netflix
bought three or whatever okay right so
I've got two I've got two Ops okay I'd
like to either see it go to a uh like a
Swiss Ski Show Oh
I like that too because you could do
like kind of a cabin fever or like
Snowden yeah I mean they couldn't leave
the islanding glass anymore they had a
lot of space to work with or or a like
Monte Carlo uh Casino like really lavish
uh casino gambling okay okay for me I
want them to like I think this next one
should be like been then they think
bring it home bring it home wait what
about a table of gamblers like a Pokemon
yeah like a final table oh that's fun
too and it's yeah I would you know
there's like this kind of genre of movie
that is like a sequence film you know
like Mad Max Fury Road is kind of a
sequence film you get like I think one
night and then it picks up later but
that movie's pretty linear like it takes
place within the film it'd be so fun to
do a Knives Out movie where it like kind
of just takes place within the runtime
yeah at the final table
in time no that was Justin Timberlake
Johnny Depp did a movie that Nick of
Time nick of time that is a uh movie
happens in the in real time yeah
basically fun uh not great
Aquaman for our Movie Club here before
we get to this we were talking earlier
too so uh uh Knives Out Radiohead song
oh okay Glass Onion Beatles song we got
it at the end credits is there a band is
there a band that we're like oh It's
gotta be I think the next the next Ryan
Johnson Benoit Bang movie will be called
Hit Me Baby One More Time oh it's a
domestic abuse movie no uh okay sorry
it's a baby murder
oh no oh my God you are gonna murder a
baby
I'm not gonna murder a dog I'm gonna
consume it if it lives during the
passing through my body then it's
nothing I can do about it uh all right
I'm gonna say uh two two choices one The
Gambler oh I like that by Kenny lawr
Kenny Rogers uh and then the other one
would be of course
um
uh Darling Nikki by Prince
Darling Nikki I'm going uh he did sort
of like
uh what what genre would you call
Radiohead sort of like uh okay sure
trash then you've got like you know like
kidding I love radio it's just pure pop
music with the Beatles I think he's
getting a classical we're gonna do a
little Vivaldi's of the Four Seasons
for every movie club we do here at the
break room we're gonna rank a movie out
of five five being the highest points
you can give but you can give any
decimal in between okay okay so out of
five knives how many knives do you give
Knives Out oh I'm gonna go and and I
hate to be such a simp for the first
movie we did no I'm gonna give it five
oh elegant heavy duty oh Japanese steel
station oh serrated blades cut through
the meat like nothing but also a little
weight to the handle so yeah I'm happy
with the knife well balanced five
gorgeous Japanese steak incredible
incredible beautiful I mean I gotta go
you know watching this again I had so
much fun again really great to delve
back into a really well done movie you
can't really fault it too much I'm gonna
go four point eight knives yeah yeah
uh I'm going like those hunt those bow
hunter knives
Bowie David Bowie
um you know it's rating systems are so
weird right it's not Citizen Kane uh
it's more enjoyable than that it's yours
John within the genre though within the
genre of murder mystery there are some
movies that I prefer I like more clue
being one of them that I really love I
love a thriller that's a little bit more
kind of like hard-boiled in the little
it does it takes itself a little bit
more serious yeah right but yeah I do
um right now tomorrow Live Die Repeat
yeah I do like that movie
um I'm right there with you 4.75 I'd say
yeah yeah you're already there first an
aggregate score of
we'll throw out the lowest and the
highest and give it a four a lot of
people in the chat putting in their
knives ratings a lot of fours and fives
um yeah it's great move we picked a good
movie on purpose right yeah
bro but thank you again to nordvpn for
sponsoring break room all this week and
making our movie compostable again we're
gonna do it next again next month check
out nordvpn.com break room get yourself
that deal uh you be safe online folks
it's dangerous out there it is it's the
wild west out there hey fellas yeah it's
time for mandatory fun oh sorry
uh but instead of a mandatory fund I
want to know what are you guys gonna do
for fun this weekend oh that's a great
question yeah uh uh am I allowed to say
this yeah you could say whatever I'm
probably gonna be watching episode three
of The Last of Us oh he's the head of
the game getting ready for our after
uh you know honestly to stay on the same
train I haven't played The Last of Us
Part Two oh I need to crack that open
I'm still stuck just grinding away you
know Assassin's Creed Valhalla will the
game ever end also I'm still playing
that Marvel snap all right if you see me
out there I mean Jubilee okay look out I
like that Odin card uh extra double
reveals watch out for me uh if you see
them in the streets you better you
better you better come correct okay you
better have a full deck yes you got a
big day on Sunday Saturday plans I've
got a big day on Sunday Saturday plans
are I'm gonna clean my house but I'm
also gonna watch Last of Us catch up so
that I can join uh Smart Watch along
with you guys and I want to give a
recommendation if anyone is in the LA
area Brandon and I got a chance to see
the Empire strips back at the mountain
Bond theater it was it truly blew every
expectation I had away is a Star Wars
parody yes burlesque show it's it's not
it's funny yeah it leaves heavier on the
Star Wars and humor than it does on the
titillating images no pun intended don't
bring your 13 year old yeah
it is certainly only for adults but it
is so much fun yeah they take very good
care of you there I think feverup.com is
the website to get tickets uh yeah I
just can't recommend it highly enough go
bills you even bought merch uh yeah I
even got this beautiful shirt and
they're they're they're in the Los
Angeles area right now they're going to
be in San Diego next month
check it out
cancellation it was a really good show
thanks for having us there yes thank you
Russell and uh yeah really good dancing
too I mean like beautiful artistic
dancing wonderful stuff blew away all
any expectations
uh great uh that's all I got for you
guys go bills Josh Allen please deliver
us or win uh please so I can come to
work on Monday I'm taking the best yeah
for my sake please let the bills in I
don't know uh but thank you all for
tuning in today on this Friday we hope
having a great Friday our next episode
of the break room is going to be on
Sunday night it's going to come out
after The Last of Us airs we won't be
here on Monday we'll be back on Monday
live watch episode two of The Last of Us
check out our after show it'll be myself
Jessica oh and watch my Mandalorian
video please Tommy's got a Mandalorian
video on the channel right now Whitney
just put out a video breaking down the
Scream Six trailer there's some good
stuff in that video everything yeah
everybody is unbelievable I I've seen
some screams I'm a scaredy cat little
boy uh but I've seen some screams but
she she really pulled out all the
details this screen looks insane I'm
very excited about it Eric's got a video
coming out uh very soon breaking down
the new posters yes
he found some kind of weird connection
about the stringy Ant-Man stuff
I haven't watched the video yet but uh
but check them all out but please oh
have a good weekend yes we're begging
you to be safe come see us again Sunday
and then I'll see you again on Tuesday
yeah that's right have a great weekend
uh we love you all uh late let's get
this see your roomies later have a good
time Breakers goodbye
[Music]
foreign